judge amy coney barrett is expected to
be president donald trump's pick
to fill ruth bader ginsburg's seat on
the u.s supreme court
he's hoping she'll become the court's
all-important sixth conservative vote
if confirmed by the senate barrett at 48
years old could shape the high court for
decades
a president has a bigger impact on the
court the longer the justice
he or she appoints stays in office she's
long expressed her affinity for the late
justice antonin scalia whom she clerked
for in the supreme court
and his support for originalism or
interpreting the constitution according
to its
original meaning justice scalia's
philosophy of judging was not only
right as a matter of the constitutional
structure
but it was also self-discipline barrett
returned to her alma mater to launch her
academic career
she still teaches law at notre dame she
became well-known in conservative legal
circles and spoke to audiences around
the country about what the supreme
court's role
should not be when it comes to social
change
when legislative change is slow because
people increasingly see the court as a
political institution when they can't
accomplish things in the legislature
they try to litigate it and then declare
a fast rin through the court because
they think it's faster
to get it through the justices than to
convince their citizens and
citizens in the legislative process she
offered as an example the issue of
transgender students
who were seeking access to the restrooms
that match their gender identity
lawyers for transgender students argued
that under a 1972 civil rights law
their clients rights were being violated
the part of the law
prohibiting discrimination in education
based on sex
is known as title ix it's a coup decides
question when title ix was enacted
it's pretty clear that no one including
the congress that enacted that statute
would have dreamed of that result
at that time maybe things have changed
so that we should change title ix
but it does seem to strain the text of
the statute to say that title
ix demands it in her 2017 appellate
court confirmation hearings
barrett emphasized time and again that a
judge's personal opinions
shouldn't matter i think if i express a
personal view
on any of these matters it might give
the misimpression that my personal view
is what would drive
the decision of a case i would not
stipulate that that won't happen
as for her personal view on landmark
supreme court rulings
barrett wouldn't budge even when those
questions came from republicans who
supported her nomination
what did you think about the opinion i
wasn't alive when griswold
came down well what about when you first
read it
well gosh senator i think again whatever
i might have thought about it i first
read it when i was a law student
but whatever i would have thought about
it then or whatever i would think about
it
today wouldn't matter i would put that
aside
in griswold v connecticut in 1965 the
supreme court found a state law which
prevented married couples from using
contraception
to be unconstitutional the court's
opinion recognized within the
constitution
a right to privacy do you believe
there's a right to privacy under the
constitution
the court has quite clearly held that
there is and
do you agree with the court senator
blumenthal
i would follow all court precedent and
whether i agree or disagree
would be beside the point to the
discharge of my duties if i were
confirmed as well
you have no personal views on whether
there's a right to privacy in the
constitution
well senator i think the question is
whether i have personal views that would
be appropriate to share
in this context given the misimpression
it could give litigants
who might appear before me if i were
confirmed both democrats and republicans
asked barrett whether she'd seek to
overturn roe v wade
if confirmed would you follow supreme
court precedent involving
abortion absolutely i would do you think
roe v wade was correctly decided
well senator i'm sorry that i feel like
i can't as a nominee
offer an opinion because i don't want to
give the impression that i would treat
some precedents as more binding or more
valuable than others
i would apply roe and its progeny just
like i would apply all supreme court
president
the senate confirmed barrett to the 7th
circuit court of appeals in chicago by
a vote of 55 to 43 there she began to
establish her judicial record
in 2019 she described an example of how
she applied her principles
in a case involving second amendment
rights for felons
after serving all of the arguments the
historically based arguments
for the constitutionality of depriving
felons of their right to
possess firearms that there was no
blanket authorization to just take guns
the right to possess a gun
away from someone who committed a felony
progressives worry that barrett would
create a more conservative supreme court
that could block their aspirations
barrett has long said she believes the
public through their elected
representatives rather than the courts
should lead the way in social change the
who decides question just as a personal
matter is really
important to me and so
i guess i i worry
a lot you know about that who decides
question um
about our decisions or you know and my
voice kind of getting taken away
now barrett may herself become the one
who decides